when I do a consult for a prenup the
first thing I do is here's what's going
to happen legally if you marry without a
prenup here's what happens to your
rights and obligations
then
what we can change with that there's
almost no limit you can you can amend
anything you want to the example I
always give is there was a case that
went up to the Appellate Court where
High net worth guy married a very
beautiful woman and there was a
provision in the prenuptial agreement
that said for every 10 pounds she gained
during the marriage she would lose ten
thousand dollars a month in alimony if
they divorced
and there was here's a baseline weight
as of the time of execution of this
agreement and I wondered if she was like
a like did like what a wrestler does
like did she like you know yeah did she
like right before and then cut when she
eventually got divorced like is she in
there with sauna you know with the suit
on
um but but the and the Appellate Court
essentially said
um I don't know why you married this
person having had them make you sign
this but it's binding yeah but it's fine
I wish somebody would do a contract like
that like like the rent for this place
would be more expensive if I was fatter
and cheaper if I was skinnier and that
way I would have to weigh in
motivation like some motivation on you
yeah exactly that's that kind of prenup
is motivating well what's his name I
think Tim Ferriss says that about how he
does like um
he said you should make Bets with people
like it's like if you gain this much I
gotta give you this amount of money you
know he says that in one of his early
books and trying to make it binding
somehow which is tough yeah I think when
we create incentives of that kind you
know that's why like there was like the
no not November or No Shave November or
you know sober like all this it was a
competition when people make a
competition of something they gamify
something it you know makes it something
that people are more likely to stick
with so